Disney fans were over the moon when they
found out that frozen 2 was under wraps
they've been trying to decipher the
film's original trailer ever since it
first came out and now some information
has just been brought to light keep
watching to find out why Olaf is so
worried about Elsa in February of 2019
Walt Disney Animation Studios released
the official trailer for frozen - this
sequel is set to hit the big screen on
November 22nd 2019 and it's bound to be
a jaw-dropper unlike most Disney movies
frozen - appeals to both the younger and
older generations fans of the franchise
think it'll be everything they expect
and more so yeah expectations are at an
all-time high
Disney has kept quiet about the sequel
ever since the first frozen - trailer
made its grand appearance but now a new
information has recently made headlines
brand-new footage from the sequel was
showcased during a Disney investors
event in early April
but while footage of these clips have
yet to appear on the Internet
CNET revealed two secret scenes that
have fans scratching their heads in
disbelief let's start with the first new
tidbit of information after viewing the
never-before-seen footage
CNET revealed a very puzzling scene
which included the brave Anna of
arendelle and her snowy pal Olaf
according to them they saw a clip of on
a kneeling before Olaf with a concerned
look on her face
Olaf then goes on to say I don't think
else is okay for this revealing piece of
information confirms what some fans had
expected that anna isn't done looking
out for her big sister just yet we're so
used to seeing olaf being his old
positive and happy self that it's hard
to picture him any other way so we can
only imagine that something big is going
to happen to Elsa and by big we mean
huge after all Olaf didn't seem too
concerned when Elsa unleashed an eternal
winter and what can be worse than that
if you thought Olaf's statement was
confusing we didn't tell you here this
next one according to C net the magical
trolls also made an appearance during
the Disney Plus event the investors were
shown a voiceover of a troll saying you
must find the truth now whether the
troll is speaking to Anna or Elsa as a
mystery still it's safe to say that
whoever is hearing this revelation is
about to embark on an epic journey the
trolls have played a huge plot in
arendelle history which is why else's
father knew to seek them out in times of
crisis but how much do these little
bolder shaped trolls know about Elsa's
powers is Elsa about to find out the
truth about her origins since Elsa and
Anna's parents passed away when they
were young they never got a chance to
pass on any family secrets so perhaps
the troll is helping the girls fulfill
their destiny but why now and what's the
end goal according to C be frozen to is
rumoured to be about Queen I'd Doudna
and King ignores disappearance all the
girls know is that their parents passed
away during a shipwreck so many years
ago some vans believe that Elsa's quest
will lead her to Tarzan's door and that
a family reunion is underway however
others suspect that a new and uninvited
threat will come to arendelle causing
the sisters to be separated and
challenged hopefully their journeys will
cause answers to sprout where questions
once stood
we know that King Agner and Queen I do
know were proud of Elsa's powers
some might even say that they saw them
as normal so look at this truth be and
why did the trolls wait all this time
before telling Elsa and Anna that there
was a truth to be found by now we all
know that Elsa and Anna are Tarzan's
older sisters frozen director Chris Bock
confirms during an interview with MTV us
that King Agner and Queen I do know
survived the shipwreck and had Tarzan on
a castaway island despite the news
frozen fans haven't considered the
possibility of a Tarzan slash frozen
crossover could finding out the truth
lead Elsa to get stranded on this very
same Island after all we did see her
struggling to get off a rocky shore
during the trailer although she could
very well be training for something big
she could also be trying to get home
could this explain why Olaf is so
worried about her who wouldn't be
worried about their friend if they
suddenly went missing perhaps frozen to
will end with Elsa and Anna discovering
that their parents had a baby boy on
some faraway Island can you say three
cool frozen to is going to focus on
developing Anna and Elsa's back stories
while shining a light on some new and
interesting characters actress Kristen
Val who voices Anna told CV that she had
a hand in developing on a story
frozen writer Jennifer Lee took
Kristen's own personal life events into
account when creating the sequel doing
this ensure that Kristen and Anna would
have a lot in common which is bound to
strengthen their bond
so what's Ana's next hurdle well
apparently she'll be tasked with helping
her sister figure out the truth
coincidentally she'll also find out a
lot about herself along the way fans
believe that Anna has been suppressing
powers of her own ever since the trolls
wiped her memory clean of magic could
honest subconscious powers be join with
the serene kingdom of arendelle or is
there a new and unforeseeable threats
coming their way whatever the case may
be expect to see how much older and
wiser Anna come frozen to
Walt Disney Animation Studios has
confirmed that a documentary series
called into the unknown making frozen to
is being commissioned it's set to
premiere on Disney Plus and will feature
mini behind-the-scenes moments
Jennifer Lee also announced that frozen
2 will feature a song titled
into the unknown which could very well
give let it go a run for its money
if the song's title is any indication of
what's to come it's safe to say that
Elsa and Anna are going up against
something entirely new the sisters will
delve into their past while trying to
make way for a brighter future
so are you guys excited to hear the
sequels new and exciting soundtrack or
are you convinced that no song can ever
come close to let it go let us know in
the comments and while you're at it let
us know if you have any theories of your
own and that's a wrap if you're as
excited for the sequel as we are hit
that subscribe button to stay up to date
with the latest frozen 2 news and before
you go don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up thanks for watching the
things we'll catch you next time
[Music]